in today's morning rounds a special type
of milk first developed in Australia
that's quickly catching on right here in
the US the makers of a2 milk claim it's
easier on the stomach than regular milk
it contains only a two proteins regular
milk has both a1 and a2 proteins
people who find regular milk hard to
digest say this is good news Don Dahler
shows us why the dairy industry is not
so sure done good morning good morning
rounds I feel like a doctor here at
first glance you might think this milk
product is another plant-based drink
like almond milk but it is not it's pure
cow's milk it has no special additives
and it's not lactose free the difference
is a type of protein found in the milk
and the makers say the difference can be
life-changing four years ago Lisa Montes
auntie says her grandson Nicholas stop
drinking milk after being hit with
severe stomach pain the symptoms went
away when he stopped drinking milk but
when he saw a commercial for a product
called a - milk he told his grandmother
he wanted to try it I got it for him and
has absolutely no problems when he
drinks it it's a natural innovation if
you will Blake Waltrip is the chief
executive of a - milk in the US there's
a one and there's a two and we simply go
and find the cows that only produce a -
proteins and that's what we have in our
milk Waltrip says that for some people
it's the a1 protein that makes milk
difficult to digest more than likely
everything that we see points to the
fact that that intolerance is - the a1
protein not to lactose they think that
they're lactose intolerant but they're
actually they have a problem with the a1
protein that's correct
a study funded by the a2 milk company
claims that when a one proteins are
broken down in the gut they form a
protein fragment called B C m7 that
triggers inflammation and symptoms like
bloating and abdominal pain but the
National Dairy Council says at this
point a twos claims are purely
theoretical and not backed by any
scientific research it's just a theory
at this point in time there is no
science that really says that there's
any value in this
relative to conventional milk to studies
that have done where with small number
of subjects looked at different
variables that really don't give us the
answer that we need to be able to tell
whether or not this is really true or
not some of the a2 milk sold in stores
is produced here at Prairieland dairy in
Firth Nebraska where the milk from
hundreds of cows that produce the a2
protein is collected interestingly the
cows that produce a2 milk are not
genetically modified to identify the
ones producing the a2 protein a simple
DNA test is performed on newborn calves
using hair follicles
they are then separated from the rest of
the herd so there's no
cross-contamination the milk lines must
be separated and cleaned thoroughly
once bottled the product must be tested
again the testing isn't cheap now the
testing isn't cheap but it's it's
reflected you know in bringing this
product to market a tube milk is sold at
a premium price roughly nine dollars per
gallon compared to around five dollars
per gallon for regular milk so these
calves have all been bred for the a -
protein that's right dan rice is the
farms owner despite skepticism from the
dairy industry rice predicts that a -
milk is the way of the future
yeah I think the industry eventually
will be all lay - but for now the
process is time-consuming and costly yet
despite the higher cost Lisa Montes
auntie says she still doesn't feel
milked for her money
I had recommended it to plenty of
anybody who says they can't drink milk
I'll say try it it's worth it now while
the dairy industry doesn't think a -
milk
science is there yet it says it welcomes
innovation and promoting consumer choice
for now a - milk is mostly sold in
specialty or high in grocery stores but
the company says it expects to make a
larger rollouts
in the near future and it tastes like
milk it's it is milk that's great it's
gonna be good news for a lot of people
who do have digestive issues you might
want to just try it and see if they can
drink this as opposed to you know the
lactose free milk I see what my sisters
worth it how do they make a chocolate
version of everybody I say yes the brown
cows produced the chopped